[music]
I'm ready.
I'm ready now. Going to open [music] up
the door and let my heart [singing] out.
Want to tell you. I'm going to say it
all.
[music]
Say it all.
Say it. Say it all. [music]
Why you're running?
Why you're running now? [music]
You're running out of reasons to escape
now. You got to listen. [music] Listen
to your heart.
Listen,
listen. [music]
[music] Heat. Heat. Heat.
[music]
See the way we're going to make it if we
just believe if we just believe.
Keep moving. [music] You got to make the
move. Listen to the rhythm of your heart
and find your own groove. You [music]
got to say it. You got to say it loud.
You got to say it loud. Speak now. Speak
now. Speak now.
Speak now. Speak now.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat.
Maybe you will see the way we're going
to make it. If we just believe. If we
just [music] believe.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed that
taste of flow from yours truly out in
the deep snow and the deep cold, but it
was still a good time. Uh, real quickly,
if you want to grab a set of those Orb
Pro LED contact po that I was using in
this video, you can do so and get a
discount on them when you use the code
Drexfactor with a zero instead of an O
at checkout over at ultraoy.com. Once
again, that is drexfactor with a zero
instead of an O. Thank you so much to
Ultraoy for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to get out and flow
even when the weather is frightful. And
speaking of thank yous, uh, I owe thanks
to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, [music] Pyroer,
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support Flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I've got down in the description of
this video. And finally, this video and
all the videos on this channel would not
exist were it not for my amazing
supporters on Patreon. In particular,
I'd love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now. Thank you so much. You all rock.
And if you are interested in getting
your name in the credits or access to a
host of other awesome rewards, you can
check out my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and sign up. I'll leave the link down in
the description as well as up in the
cards. Please check that out and help me
out in my mission to bring PO spinning
and flow arts to the whole wide world.
Thank you in advance. And if you would
like to check out my other flow videos,
I'll go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of those down in the
description as well as up here on
screen. Thanks so much for watching.
Make sure to get out and flow yourselves
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care. Peace.